well Donald Trump announced his
presidency last night as you've probably
heard I thought I'd begin the show with
his address and we will still talk about
it of course but there was another
speech yesterday one with far less
significant political implications
but which reflects the state of our
society in a way that
a few speeches ever have or could and
needless to say not in a good way so an
an as yet unnamed woman and a
self-professed black supremacist quote
unquote recently posted a video to tick
tock of as she says the eulogy that she
gave her father at his funeral
uh the eulogy went viral on Tick Tock
before making its way over to Twitter on
Tuesday and then out into the mainstream
media Outlets who are reporting on it
now which is how the pipeline usually
works now her father apparently died of
liver cancer which is something that I
only know because she also posted tick
tock's joking about her father's cancer
um how and why would you make jokes
about your own father's terminal cancer
what sort of person would do such a
thing well
um this sort of person actually
but Dad please know that while I'm
grateful and highly aware of all that
you've given this family I still don't
miss you when you died I felt like there
was a hole I missed something but it
wasn't you it was the idea of what you
could become
I miss being able to Hope and wish that
one day you turn a corner and see the
world from my perspective I miss the
idea that one day you might help me
fight for the things that matter I
missed my fantasy of you
because when you died it solidified the
fact that she'll never be what you could
have been but only what you are and what
you are is a racist misogynistic
xenophobic trump-loving sister white
male that is all you will ever be to me
and Dad before you tell me to respect
the dead please remember that you
disrespected and disregarded the lives
and death as the entire communities of
people with your ideology you told me to
Never back down so I won't you know for
a fact that even against you I'm not
afraid to share my peace you are
everything I Aspire not to be and I
refuse to stand up here and sing the
praise of a man who was the Paradigm of
white supremacy so I'll take your racist
mindset I'll take your money and I'll
take your advice and I swear to God I
will make this world a better place not
at all because of you but an exact
opposition to you
think
I'll take your money she says and I I
bet you will now it's hard to know who
to despise more the woman spitting on
her own father's grave or the people in
the audience applauding it I suppose we
need not choose one or the other now we
should acknowledge from the outset that
not every person who dies necessarily
deserves to be mourned you don't become
a good person just because you happen to
die some of us have been to funerals
where the eulogies are conspicuously
brief because there isn't much good to
say about the deceased that's just the
reality I mean if you don't if you if
you don't live as a good person then uh
people are not required to pretend
otherwise after you die and if you let's
say abused or neglected your children
then they are under no obligation to
sing your Praises upon your death
yet we can reasonably assume that such
was not the case in this particular
instance she doesn't indict him for
being abusive or neglectful quite the
opposite she actually acknowledges that
he loved and served his family rather
her charge against her father is that he
was a white straight cisgender Trump
supporter
she is half his race but it's the half
she hates and most of all as she makes
clear she hates him for not agreeing
with her in fact her love for him was
predicated on her hope and her
assumption that eventually he would
think exactly as she thinks her love was
conditional which is to say that the
love never existed at all and the
condition is that those she loves must
be perfect mirror reflections of her own
viewpoints
but death tragically interceded before
her father could realize that she was
right about everything and for that she
hates him and can never forgive him
now
if this incident had occurred in a
vacuum you know if it was entirely uh
anomalous
then there might not be much worth
saying about it this woman would simply
be an ungrateful brat with a wicked evil
heart who will not even have the honor
of being insulted at her funeral because
she'll die alone and forgotten and
there'll be no one there to insult her
in the first place that is what we might
say and leave it at that if this was a
freak occur in say total departure from
the norm
but it's not
I mean sure yeah it's it's not every day
that we see someone recite demeaning
slam poetry about their own father at
his funeral but um this is still fully
in line with the spirit of the age
in fact there's perhaps no better
manifestation of the spirit of the age
than a biracial woman lecturing her
white dad at his funeral
this is literally what the left wants
it's not an accident
it is rather the direct result of the
cultural revolution that has long since
been completed and which we are now on
the other side of
you know established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect that you so
richly deserve all you need is a one
square foot plot of land in Scotland
established titles is a Project based on
a historic Scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairs or
Lords and Ladies in English and your
title pack you'll be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in Edelson Scotland
plus an official certificate which I
have here with a Crest your certificate
features a unique plot Number with which
you can see the exact location of your
land
um title packs from established titles
are a fun and unique gift for any
occasion there are even couple packs
that come with adjoining plots of land
for that special someone in your life
with your certificate you could
officially add the prefix of Lord or
lady to your credit cards or plane
tickets and even your dating profile
established titles commits to preserving
The Woodlands not only in Scotland but
around the planet a tree is planted for
every order they receive and you
probably know this about me that was a
really important part of this deal for
me established titles told me that the
first 200 people to purchase a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within walking distance
of mine depending on how many people
sign up we could build our own kingdom
even we're taking over the globe
established titles is also running a
huge sale right now and if you use code
wall should check out you'll get an
additional 10 off go to establish
titles.com Walsh to get your gifts now
and help support the gym
so there are three ideas for attitudes
that our culture seeks to instill in
everyone but especially in the Young and
all three are manifested in that video
first of course there's narcissism
right everything's about you
and whatever is not about you should be
made to be about you
the first thing you should think when
you encounter any situation is how can I
put myself at the center of it and if
you encounter any resistance in this
effort to put yourself at the center
then you're being oppressed
indeed anyone who lives a life or who
does anything or says anything or thinks
anything that departs from your
preferences has persecuted you
for this woman her father's funeral is
about her because his death is about her
because his life was about her it was
his job to think and behave as she
demanded by failing to do so by failing
to succumb to the force of her gravity
and revolve around her as she insists he
was guilty of an unthinkable crime
right if she is not the center
that she is being erased
either either she is the star of every
film or else she doesn't exist there is
no middle ground
this is the lesson she learned from the
culture from the school system the media
from every institution loud and clear
second there is dehumanization
those who disagree with you who have
opinions that are not your own and
values you object to are not simply
wrong they are sub-human you shouldn't
merely disagree with them you should
despise them they're not worthy of
respect or even life itself this is a
message that I hear every time I visit
my inbox
I'm informed that I'm a you know a
racist xenophobic transphobic Etc and
therefore I should die and my family
should die and whenever I do die I am
told there will be celebration in the
streets I don't doubt it either
see we make a mistake when we assume
that all of this kind of talk is just
sort of meaningless internet trolling
and it might be trolling
but it also reflects what is actually in
the hearts of millions of people
like when you're online and you say your
opinion and you've got uh three dozen
people telling you to kill yourself for
your opinion
it's not well it's not real that's not
that's not the real world no it's it's
real I mean that you're in the world and
these are actual people saying that to
you
because that is indeed how they feel
about you and your opinion
they have been conditioned to think this
way
again we kid ourselves if we tell
ourselves anything about that
if you have views that that oppose their
views then you are automatically a bigot
and if you are a bigot then you are an
inferior life form you're a cockroach a
parasite
she applies this logic even to her own
father which is no surprise given the
third point
the Third
is that the family is an oppressive
patriarchal conspiracy and your parents
and all of your ancestors going back to
the generations are ignorant backwards
Crow Magnum cave dwellers
the last goal as always is to break
apart
not just the nuclear family in the
abstract as a sort of concept
but to dismantle your actual family
it's not the family that is that is
being threatened I mean it is the the
family on a broad societal level but
what you have to understand it's also
your family your actual family
they want to pull your children away
from you
sever the ties That Bind you together
they would like for us all to be
eulogized by our children in this way
that's what the constant campaign of
brainwashing is working towards
and and where it leads ultimately is to
misery of course for everybody involved
because whatever else you might say
about this young woman and you could say
quite a lot about her much of it not fit
to air but one thing you cannot say is
that she's happy
this is a wretched miserable person
trained to reject everything that might
threaten to imbue her life with meaning
and joy
because that's the thing when you
when you want to be the center of the
universe and when you hate everyone who
disagrees with you
and when you hate your own family
and you hate your own bloodline
that's just another way of saying that
you hate yourself you hate your own
existence
you hate existence itself
because you wouldn't exist without any
of that that this is the this is the the
nature of of the world
there is in fact only one universe and
you're not at the center of it this is
the only Universe we have
and
so if you can't accept that then you
hate existence for what it is
and that's why we must protect our
children from this madness
so that we don't have them dancing on
our Graves once we have passed on and so
that
they can live a better life
than the one that our culture wants to
give them
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]